mit dem eigenen flugzeug sind wir
unterwegs von kabul nach masar i scharif
es ist eine reise in die vergangenheit
ohne nostalgie aber vor der hoffnung
denn es hat sich viel getan
putin der direktor des orthopädie
zentrum sind kabul besucht nach vielen
jahren seinen berufskollegen seit über
30 jahren betreibt das ikk mehrere
orthopädischer einrichtungen in
afghanistan
früher gab es hier nur wüste
da war nichts ich erinnere mich an
dieses gas mit einem lastwagen brachten
sie die wurzeln hierher zwei personen
kultivierten diese erde und jetzt
wachsende gras und sogar große bäume es
ist ein richtiger garten geworden
stolz präsentiert der kollegin nadine
das zentrum in der vorhergehenden folge
der hintner turin viel anerkennung
seine unterweisung von kriegs wurden
fand gehör
in kolumbien steht abraham to play doh
einer familie bei deren sohn wurde von
einer bewaffneten gruppe getötet
stéphanie erbrachte im gazastreifen der
blinden mutter eines palästinensischen
häftlings licht und hoffnung
präsident peter maurer traf sich mit
bundesrat burkhalter für beide ein
erfolgreiches gipfeltreffen
[Musik]
das zentrum wird von ehemaligen
patienten betrieben der kollege zeigten
als putin die therapie mit einer
zerebral gelähmten mädchen
es soll einfache bewegungsabläufe lernen
guten tag
das mädchen macht kleine fortschritte
aber es gibt grenzen die wünsche der
eltern sind zumeist überhöht und sie zu
erfüllen nicht möglich sie denken mit
einer behandlung können die kinder
wieder ein normales leben führen wie
alle anderen
wir versuchen die kinder zu
stabilisieren und ihnen das leben
leichter zu machen
[Musik]
kürzlich war ein kind hier es ist
ungefähr sechs jahren an seine eltern
sagten mir es habe noch nie einen
schritt gemacht
wir arbeiteten mit ihm eine woche lang
dann konnte es ein zwei schritte machen
das macht mich glücklich ein hausbesuch
steht an gemeinsam mit einem
physiotherapeuten aus dem zentrum fahren
wie er in eines der ärmeren quartiere
der stadt
natur dienen und der therapeut mohammad
omar tragen beide beinprothesen
[Musik]
die familie die wir besuchen lebt in
großer armut
der patient war früher maurer er fiel
vom dach und ist seither gelähmt
seine frau ist gestorben um den
paraplegiker assadullah russ 1 kümmert
sich das ikk seit fünf jahren so sieht
hier das wahre leben aus wie alt ist ein
älterer sohn acht jahre und deine
tochter sie ist sechs jahre alt als
matula husain hat kein bett das ist
unerschwinglich er ist wund gelegen
der physiotherapeut behandelt ihn
regelmäßig diese menschen haben ein
wirklich hartes leben
die spitäler neben solche patienten
nicht auf zum glück sind die wunden
teilweise verheilt gesäubert und nicht
mehr infiziert aber manchmal kommen
menschen ins zentrum bei denen man die
knochen sehen kann so tief sind die
wunden
eigentlich wäre es die aufgabe der
spitäler sich um diese menschen zu
kümmern
hier sieht man wie sie leben müssen
sie kriegen schnell druckgeschwüre weil
sie nichts mehr spüren
auf wiedersehen alles gute
weil ich jemanden in einem so miserablen
zustand sehe treibt mich das an
weiterzumachen und einen weg zu finden
um zu helfen
mit ganz wenig kann man viel bewirken
das kostet fast nichts aber es verändert
das leben der menschen
das geht einem hoffnung und energie um
weiterzumachen
[Musik]
in kolumbien steht der ikk delegierte
abraham tobago vor einem einsatz der die
frage nach dem sinn humanitäre arbeit
aufkommen lässt eine indigene
dorfgemeinschaft die vertrieben wurde
hat die nun hilfe gebeten und alles
bereit
[Musik]
die fahrt auf dem fluss adra dauert
mehrere stunden dieser wasserweg ist
strategisch wichtig für die bewaffneten
gruppen und die drogenbanden
das militär ist kaum präsent
die indigenen wurden von einer
bewaffneten gruppe aus ihrem heimatdorf
vertrieben
solche aktionen kommen hier immer wieder
vor die betroffenen gehören zum stamm
der mph katja das dorf bellavista
gewährt ihnen vorerst im gemeindehaus
unterschlupf abraham war schon einmal
hier um die bedürfnisse abzuklären
inzwischen hat er für diese 90 menschen
eine verteilaktion organisiert guten tag
es freut mich euch wiederzusehen
mitarbeiterin diana wird alles erklären
aber namen sind nicht wichtig wichtig
ist nur dass wir uns wieder erkennen
stellt alle fragen die euch beschäftigen
wir sind hier um euch zu zuhören was
passiert mit den ganz kleinen kindern
wie zum beispiel dieser süßen hier denen
unter zwei jahren für sie finden sie im
paket eine mail design für die haupt
und eine creme für den po die kann man
auch um die genitalien herum benutzen
das ist eine creme dann gibt es auch ein
shampoo für die kleinen
es ist ein spezielles kids also ein
paket für die babys das ikea kann diese
indigenen nur für kurze zeit
unterstützen
danach sind sie wieder sich selber
überlassen nachhaltig ist diese hilfe
nicht
es gibt immer wieder frustrierende
momente erleben monetären arbeit man
fragt sich ob das alles sinn macht ob
man überhaupt etwas verändern kann oder
ob man bloß löcher stopft oder noch
schlimmer
ob man gar dazu beiträgt dass ein
konflikt anhält das sind ethische fragen
aber ich vergesse sie sobald ich leben
retten kann
sie treten in den hintergrund wenn ich
menschen frauen hungrigen kindern helfen
und in sicherheit und schutz geben kann
dann ist das alles gerechtfertigt aber
klar die fragen sind in meinem kopf
bella vista liegt nahe am äquator es
wird schnell dunkel
jetzt packen alle mit an bewaffnete
gruppen verdächtigt die unter den
indigenen kollaborateure und spione
darum wurden sie vertrieben und mussten
alles zurücklassen
die verteilung der überlebens kids
gehört zum klassischen hilfsprogramm
wir kontrollieren die qualität der
produkte bevor wir sie verteilen die
sachen die wir verteilen sollen gut und
nützlich sein
[Musik]
so wechsele nahrungsmittel kochgeschirr
decken und matratzen den besitzer
meine freundin meine freundin und da ist
meine andere freundin
das essgeschirr bringt es einem vater
[Musik]
wir haben 12
die nahrungsmittel und kochutensilien
helfen die größte not zu lindern
fürs erste bei einer verteilung hat man
eine unmittelbare genugtuung weil die
leute vor und dankbar sind die normale
arbeit das war frustrierend dass ich
eines tages den job wechseln möchte ich
diese anerkennung und zufriedenheit
nicht missen
es gibt natürlich auch frustrierende
momente auch bei kalkar die arbeit
verlangt eben einen langen atem
[Musik]
abraham dobler und sein team ziehen sich
für ein paar stunden schlaf zurück
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs in der provinz
nord-kivu mitten in einem der großen
dramen der welt sechs millionen tote
soll es im über 20 jährigen krieg
gegeben haben mehr als wir und
afghanistan zusammen willkommen
die ikk mitarbeiterin alles radikal
leute 23 jahren ein kinderschutz
programm mit ehemaligen kindersoldaten
maike grün ist schutz delegierte und neu
im kongo in diesem übergangsheim leben
43 knaben und sechs mädchen ihre
gesichter dürfen wir nicht zeigen um sie
zu schützen
hier sollen sie zu einem normalen leben
zurückfinden
[Applaus]
guten tag und jetzt noch etwas lauter
wir sind hierher gekommen um euch zu
helfen jetzt die begebe ich einmal heißt
wie so reagiert ihr nicht er wird euch
erklären wer sie ist und was sie hier
macht
ich wohne jetzt in koma aber eigentlich
komme ich aus holland
ich bin mit alice hier um euch von den
aktivitäten des ikk und des roten
kreuzes zu erzählen und um mit euch über
eure rückkehr zu sprechen
wir hoffen dass sie alle zu euren
familien und dörfern zurückkehren könnte
deshalb sind wir hier weil diese
jugendlichen noch bis vor kurzem mit
kalaschnikows brandschatzen durch die
dörfer zogen müssen sie racheakte
befürchtet und in den augen ihrer
ehemaligen soldaten kollegen sind sie
die akteure
wie immer in diesem gebiet muss man
nicht lange auf den nächsten regen
warten und die ganze gruppe zieht um und
das dach
[Applaus]
er spielte basketball lernt ihr sonst
noch etwas was lernt ihr sonst noch
rolle spiele und was machen wir noch wir
zeigen euch wie man anpflanzt und den
boden bearbeitet maike grün besichtigt
derweil mit dem vize direktor die
mädchentoiletten die sind aber sauberer
als bei den jungs ja die sind gut
organisiert
im schlafsaal der jungen ist es eng über
40 knaben schlafen hier
sie haben menschen verletzt und getötet
die erinnerungen an gräueltaten lassen
die meisten nicht los die gespenster
verfolgen sie bisher nicht alle kinder
hier haben dieselbe konstitution
es gibt welche die stärke traumatisiert
sind als andere
[Musik]
die einen mehr die anderen weniger
es gibt kinder wie kamen direkt aus dem
kampfgebiet
einige unter ihnen sind ziemlich brutal
andere haben überhaupt keine geduld
diese kinder brauchen sehr viel
betreuung der weg zurück in ein normales
leben ist lang
[Musik]
was mich am meisten beeindruckt selbst
diese kinder die wegen ihrem verhalten
als schwierig gelten
ich finde sie sehr sympathisch
sie lachen diskutieren tauschen sich aus
spielen und nehmen an diskussionen teil
sie vergessen all das schreckliche das
sie erlebt haben
sie steuern ein ganz normales leben an
wie andere kinder auch
das beeindruckt mich ist das eine
verlorene generation für mich nicht im
gegenteil es ist eine gewonnene
generation alles musiker will uns
ehemalige kindersoldaten vorstellen die
es geschafft haben und heute wieder in
einem dorf integriert sind
[Musik]
es ist sechs uhr morgens stefanie l r
die delegierte aus lausanne fährt mit
dem team zu einem der größten
gefängnisse israels 800 männer sind hier
inhaftiert
ramon mitten in der wüste negev die
parkplätze im schatten sind reserviert
ich kann nicht passieren
hier sitzen viele langzeitgefangene aus
gaza
im team dabei ist ein arzt er will mit
allen ländern die im hungerstreik sind
sprechen wir haben eine drehbewegung und
begleitend der familie in den
vorratsraum der kantine
hier führt sie die gespräche drei
personen unterzeichnen heute eine
vollmacht für angehörige dies muss in
unserem beisein geschehen ansonsten
akzeptiert dass die wand in palästina
nicht
[Musik]
der zweite fall ist ein häftling mit
jordanischen wurzeln
viele palästinenser sind doppelbürger
mit palästinensische und jordanische
nationalität
anscheinend war diese person die letzten
tage im hungerstreik
er hat jetzt aufgehört aber ich will
herausfinden was der grund war
so protestierten viele jordanier dagegen
dass sie keine familienbesuche aus
jordanien kriegten sondern nur aus der
westbank
dieser mann hat seit 2011 nur fünf
familien besucher erhalten
normalerweise haben die häftlinge aus
der westbank alle zwei wochen besuch die
aus gaza alle zwei monate
gerade als ein häftling eintreten will
greift ein israelischer wachmann 1
wir dürfen drehen aber ohne tun
stéphanie spricht mit dem palästinenser
über seine haftbedingungen das essen und
die hygiene und führt protokoll
fünf stunden später sind die interviews
beendet das team fährt zurück nach tel
aviv im gepäck die salat größe der
gefangenen an ihre familien
der tag neigt sich dem ende entgegen
das team ist zurück in tel aviv
denn trotz routine sind die besucher
anstrengend immer geht es um schicksale
jetzt brauche ich eine dusche
es war heiß heute und dann ausruhen für
die lausannerin steht bald eine reise in
die schweiz an
[Musik]
maike grün und alice musik erfahren zur
frontlinie in der region nord kivu
hier leben viele ehemalige
kindersoldaten
das ikrk armee verhindern dass sie
wieder zur waffe greifen mit job
projekten die jugendlichen bleiben weil
sie sich hier ein selbstständiges leben
aufbauen können zum beispiel mit dieser
bäckerei sie ist die attraktion im dorf
gegen 20 jugendliche stellen ihr gepäck
hier
das sichert ihnen ein kleines einkommen
ich habe sie gefragt was sie nachher mit
diesem gebäck machen
sie sagen sie werden es verkaufen wir
treffen la vie seit seinem vierzehnten
lebensjahr war ja ein kindersoldat sein
gang verrät die noch immer heute ist er
19 verheiratet und vater eines kindes
wir waren einfach zu jung und wir waren
dumm und wir wussten nicht was wir tun
sollen wenn man aber mitglied so eine
gruppe ist kann man nichts anderes tun
als die anderen zu exekutieren
die einzige intelligenz die wir hatten
war unsere waffe wir hatten überhaupt
kein benehmen
wir achten können bis von ihm uns danach
war
wir machen einfach was wir wollten ohne
nach niemand hat uns daran gehindert
auch frauen schlossen sich den
bewaffneten gruppen an
oft aus verzweiflung zum beispiel weil
sie das schulgeld nicht auftreiben
konnten
als wir bei den kämpfern ankamen merkten
wir dass das leben dort noch viel
schwieriger war als wir gedacht hatten
und nach einiger zeit merkten wir dass
es besser wäre wieder heim zu gehen
das leben war schwierig es gab dort
männer die uns einfach so zur frau nahm
und wir wollten oder nicht
so bekam ich schließlich die beiden
kindern mit der zeit wurde mir klar dass
ich auf dem falschen weg war
ich machte mir gedanken wie ich da
wieder herauskommen könnte ich
realisierte dass mir niemand helfen
konnte
dieses ständige herumirren im wald mit
zwei kleinen kindern hielt ich nicht
mehr aus doch fliehen war gefährlich
viele frauen die aus dem krieg
zurückkehren sind sozial geächtet
sie sind doppelte opfer vergewaltigt und
verlassen zugleich
[Musik]
in genf ist heute ein feiertag für das
ek es ist der geburtstag des
gründervaters original
außerdem feiert die organisation ihr 150
jähriges bestehen am volksfest ist
präsident peter maurer mit dabei er ist
immer wieder stolz auf die globaler
ausstrahlung des ikk wie stark die grund
die dvd helfer der unparteiliche hilfe
für die hilfe für alle verwundeten
unabhängige vor verweilen politischer
lager das sich immer dass das eigentlich
für chemikalien auf der welt immer nur
wahnsinnige starke idee ist so enorm
viel und motiviert die arbeit machen was
sie machen fotos oder insgesamt in der
grenze regelt wie die organisation ist
auch der präsident nahe bei den menschen
über nordkorea
du stellst aber fragen was möchtest du
denn wissen ihre meinung die ansicht des
roten kreuzes vielleicht weißt du wir
haben eine delegation in nordkorea
aber wir können sehr wenig machen weil
uns die regierung nicht machen lässt wir
haben nur medizinische und orthopädische
projekte und chirurgie die nordkoreaner
sind noch nicht so gut in der biologie
weißt du und dann helfen wir leuten die
eine hand oder einen fuß verloren haben
ich würde gerne bald einmal hin fragen
denn es gibt dort viele menschen die an
hunger leiden
komm ich besuche nicht da war dann
erzähle ich dir mehr
vielleicht fahre ich diesen sommer oder
winter
franziskus und indischen klängen
bald fällt der startschuss zum marathon
für die gute sache der familienhund
maurers ehefrau und eine der beiden
töchter aus bern sind nach genf gereist
um maurer beim marathon anzufeuern
genug der worte beginnen wir mit der
marathon
[Applaus]
[Musik]
stefanie l r ist für eine woche zurück
in der schweiz
[Musik]
in genf hat sie eine standortbestimmung
mit dem ikk von ihrer beruflichen
zukunft hat sie klare vorstellungen
klar ich sehne mich nach einer
abwechslungsreicheren mission anderen
aktivitäten als nur die gefangenen
besuche
ich könnte mir syrien oder irak
vorstellen aber wir werden sehen was
möglich ist das was mich am meisten
interessiert
nun ich will eine etwas härtere mission
eine in der ich mehr operationell tätig
bin und die vielfalt größer ist
ami krk hauptsitz werden die delegierten
bei der wahl der destination waren
gehört entscheiden dabei sind die
bedürfnisse der delegationen stefani hat
sich eine strategie zurechtgelegt
hallo wie geht's wieder zurück
ich habe schon käse gegessen
gehen wir gleich in meinem büro
dort mach ich freue mich dich zu sehen
so können wir einen überblick gewinnen
es war alles sehr positiv alles positiv
das hört man gerne ich habe nicht das
gefühl dass die luft draußen ist
ich habe gehört dass die ersten sechs
monate in einem land normalerweise
großartig sagt alles ist neu denn wo
dann kommt ein kleines tief aber meine
motivation ist jedenfalls noch voll da
und hast du schon mit seinen kollegen
besprechen können welche aktivitäten
dich interessieren
also es gibt zwei sachen die mich
besonders interessieren
die umgebung auf der einen seite und das
jobprofil auf der anderen seite mein
anspruch wenn man das so sagen darf wäre
ein arabischsprachige land
du möchtest also im arabischen raum
bleiben bis auf weiteres jahr wenn man
in tel aviv stationiert ist ist es
schwierig sein arabisch zu verbessern
ich mache jetzt zwar einen hebräisch
kurs habe man taucht nicht wirklich in
die sprache ein
deswegen würde ich gerne nochmals auf
eine mission in einer arabisch sprechen
das gebiet gehen bevor ich ganz woanders
hin wechselt damit ich es richtig gut
lernen das profil der delegierten muss
sich natürlich mit den bedürfnissen der
delegationen decken
manchmal ist der zugang aus
sicherheitsgründen oder anderen
spezifische männer einfacher in anderen
fällen ist es umgekehrt
bei frauen spezifischen problemen ist es
für männer schwieriger verbrauchtes
frauen das bestimmen die delegationen
super danke vielen dank gute rückkehr
wann fährst du wieder sonntags ich muss
noch ein paar von diese überstehen
noch mehr käse ist
genau gleich rechts wir nehmen die
treppe ist der fun i l l hofft dass ihr
wunsch nach einer mission in der sie
mittendrin ist erhört wird
[Musik]
in diesem haus in goma lebt die ikk
mitarbeiterin alles was sie kann
sie und ihr mann war unter haben vier
kinder
beide arbeiten für das ikea ein privileg
in dieser krisengeschüttelten gegend wir
haben das glück für eine große
organisation zu arbeiten
deshalb kennen uns gerüchte nicht so
viel anhaben
diese versetzen die leute nämlich in
panik unser arbeitgeber kann uns eine
gewisse sicherheit vermitteln
ich werde sie sehr lieben
fast eine reihe welt aber da sind die
fragen der kinder nach dem krieg auf die
alles keine antwort hat
wir sagen den kindern wir müssen mit dem
krieg leben dass wir all das nicht
verstehen aber dass das militär an der
front hat das sich darum kümmert das
sind keine geschichten für kinder
es reicht uns wenn wir hier spielen
ein normales leben führen können wir
sind in sicherheit das ist das was er
ihnen sagen manchmal sei es schwer diese
leichtigkeit aufrecht zu erhalten sagt
alles aber sie tut es mit aller kraft
[Musik]
in kolumbien besuchen der genfer abraham
tobago und sein team am nächsten tag die
vertriebene dorfgemeinschaft erneut
viele von ihnen trinken verschmutztes
wasser und leiden darum an durchfall
die pflegefachfrau juliana berät eine
mutter deren kind krank ist
das mädchen muss zum arzt man sieht es
im brustkorb den sie nach außen drückt
das heißt sie kann nicht gut atmen weil
sie nicht gut atmen kann kann sie nicht
gut trinken und schlafen
zudem hat sie durchfallen dieser glaube
hat eine bindehautentzündung eigentlich
unproblematisch weil die gemeinschaft
aber so eng zusammen lebt ist die
ansteckungsgefahr sehr hoch mit einer
salbe cheftrainer abhilfe
bella vista hat zwar einen
wohlklingenden namen ist aber durch ein
brutales massaker bekannt geworden über
100 unschuldige wurden hier getötet
sie gerieten zwischen die fronten von
guerillas und paramilitärs zu suchten
zuflucht in einer kirche
das geschah vor zwölf jahren ein mahnmal
hält die erinnerung wach das war eines
der schrecklichsten ereignisse in dieser
gegend menschen hatten in einer kirche
zuflucht gesucht und die kirche wurde
ziel eines angriffs für die menschen ist
das bis heute dramatisch
die politische situation in kolumbien
beschäftigt abraham friedensgespräche
zwischen der regierung und den
linksgerichteten farc rebellen sollen
eine dauerhafte lösung bringen das ist
auch abrahams hoffnung die
friedensverhandlungen geben grund zur
hoffnung so wie noch nie aber es gibt
noch viele herausforderungen
nur weil ein friedensvertrag
unterschrieben ist bedeutet das noch
nicht das ende der gewalt in kolumbien
das riesige problem mit den kriminellen
banden bleibt bestehen
diese interne gewaltsituation darunter
leiden leider sehr viele menschen in
kolumbien
trotz aller zweifel abraham hat sich
entschieden ein halbes jahr länger in
quito zu bleiben stefanie l r besucht
ihre mutter in lausanne zu ihr hat sie
engen kontakt die langen gesprächen
versucht die mutter zu verstehen wieso
stéphanie unbedingt in einem aktuellen
kriegsgebiet arbeiten will
da ist man wirklich mittendrin in einer
kriegssituation das möchte ich einmal im
leben machen dann sehe ich hab ich dafür
gemacht bilder nicht aber einmal im
leben muss das sein
syrien hätte ich doch etwas angst nicht
unbedingt wegen des aktuellen kriegs
mehr wegen dem einsatz chemischer waffen
wenn da etwas passiert kann das sehr
schlimme folgen haben für die menschen
voraus vom irak hört man auch
grauenvolle sachen attentate und so aber
es bringt nichts sich im voraussagen zu
machen
heute ist ist der fall er hat sich
durchgesetzt
die nächste mission führt die junge
delegierte in den irak nach bagdad in
eines der gefährlichsten gebiete der
welt
für peter maurer steht eine weitere
mission an der unermüdliche präsident
der sich jede nacht nur wenige stunden
schlaf gönnt ist schon wieder unterwegs
zum flughafen
maurer will sich ein eigenes bild einer
krisenregion machen
wider erwarten ihn bilder des elends
aber unerschütterlich hält er am glauben
fest dass sich etwas zum guten wenden
wird die ewige projektsituation
hauptstrom der thermik krieg etwa
aufgehört in der europäischen geschichte
die dank audi land nicht nur um ein
enormes entwicklungspotenzial sondern
durch unser tigers ehre
konfliktsituation uns wenden
danke herr ihre therapie die das
stabilisiere und überlebenshilfe soll
das
der oberste helfer weiß dass er und
seine mitarbeitenden auf der ganzen welt
auch weiterhin viel zu tun haben um den
schwächsten in kriegssituationen
beizustehen
[Musik]
für najin ist der besuch in masar i
scharif fass zu ändern
der gläubige muslim will noch einen der
wichtigsten wallfahrtsorte afghanistans
besuchen die blaue moschee
[Musik]
meine religion schreibt vor dass man die
hilfsbedürftigen unterstützen soll
es ist eine religiöse verpflichtung
denjenigen zu helfen die uns brauchen
mit dem abzug der internationalen
truppen ist die situation in afghanistan
ungewisser denn je
trotzdem will das mutti nicht aufhören
an eine friedliche lösung zu glauben wir
hoffen dass wir eines tages frieden in
unserem land haben werden und alle
friedlich zusammenleben können
wir sind umgeben von weißen tauben
sie sind das symbol des friedens
fein aufwies wir sehen uns so sehr nach
frieden im land mit diesem wunsch endet
unsere serie
für ein jahr hatten wir das einzigartige
privileg delegierte des komitee vom
internationalen roten kreuz zu begleiten
wir haben menschen kennengelernt die
sich jeden tag dafür einsetzen dass not
gelindert wird so wie sich original das
einst erträumt hatte
[Musik]